this is a production of Cornell
University thank you very much Elena the
one thing I actually spent a year
working for the USDA to sew a finger in
many pots okay so this first slide is to
characterize basically my good fortune I
was coming back from the earth within
the arab adaxes meeting was in Beijing
and I had like 48 hours in Paris and so
went to the Louvre and they had this
thing where they were taking modern art
and oh let's see if I got that and well
I don't know this thing I'm what have I
done here how can I have broken it
already so I've broken this already but
anyway baby juxtaposing modern art with
all the ancient stuff and I were
actually on it one of those living
runways out of there yes and and we
thought you know all these life-size of
plaster of Paris people wearing lab
coats and holding clocks and I thought
this is just so perfect for my lab so we
actually had to go out and come back in
so I could walk in there and take a
picture of all these people so that is
not a group meeting that's that's art
okay so the reason for my fascination
with clocks and the whole premise of the
field is is that a clock that matches
the environmental oscillation will
enhance Fitness because of course the
rotation of the earth on its axis means
that life is evolved in a world where
the environment changes drastically day
and night but completely predictably and
so if the clock is an entity that allows
the organism to coordinate its biology
with this daily oscillation in the
environment around it so that's what
we're working on and and nowhere is this
better Illustrated than in this movie
that some of you may have seen from us
Roger Han garter makes it this is this
is a sunflower plant growing in Rogers
backyards
and this is the day in the life of this
sunflower and and so this is east and
this is West and it's Indiana so not
much is going to happen but over time
the shadows will get longer and then it
will be illuminated night the action is
all at night and it will be illuminated
by a single bulb overs backcourt but you
can see the solar tracking it's been
tracking and keeping it leaves oriented
and now immediately it completely
reconfigures and there's sort of two
amazing things here one is it knows
where the sun's going to come up and
where breakfast is going to be and it
knows when it's going to happen and it's
totally ready so this is the best
example of dawn anticipation that I have
ever seen and and this is really what
clocks are about to enable you to
anticipate what's coming next and adjust
your biology to be appropriate to what's
happening next now I would like to put
this in particularly when it's not a
plant audience because I like to sort of
poke the animal folks in the eye a bit
but given that it's largely a plant
audience this hopefully will make you
all feel better about yourselves
because plants feature almost entirely
the history of study of circadian
rhythms is the study of plant circadian
rhythms in the Western canon at least
the first writings on clocks are those
of Indra Sinise who had subscribed went
off with Alexander the Great to define
and conquered the known world and he
observed leaf movement of a tree almost
certainly a tamarind on an island in the
Red Sea now we call Bahrain there was no
indication that they had any sense that
this was an endogenous self-sustaining
leaf movement but this the first writing
of science lived a little slower back
then some two millennia later a French
astronomer finally did the experiment to
ask is this endogenous and he took a
sensitive heliotrope up almost 30 a
mimosa and just put it in the dark and
asked did the sleep movements of the
leaves forces and they did he was quite
prescient because he suggested there
might be a relationship of this behavior
in plants to the observed sleep
behaviors in bedridden human patients
and hospitals and of course he was quite
right but
product of the clock again science moved
slowly 30 years later to other authors
published books repeating those
observations getting whole books out
here but they excluded temperature as
having driven these rhythms and then
finally a hundred eighty years later de
Kendall finally got quantitative up to
this point people had said okay leaves
are moving whatever they have a
circadian period a daily period but
finally de Cantel quantified the period
and determined that the freerunning curd
was not precisely 24 hours in mimosa
it's about 22 to 23 hours and and when I
entered the field we were still at the
end of a long debate with whether or not
there was such a thing as the circadian
clock or rather were these overt
phenotypes that people observed the
result of some response to some subtle
and undetected geophysical cue and of
course the answer came in here because
the period wasn't 24 hours so it
couldn't have been a subtle geophysical
cue because that would have had a
24-hour period like the rotation of the
earth on its axis so it had to be
endogenous people still didn't believe
until they finally puts an Arras weapon
Skylab removed it from the earth cycle
and it continued to show its daily
rhythm and consider Canady a ssin so uh
but up until now everything's all
implants and it wasn't until if it was
1898 when finally they observed rhythms
and pigmentation and some crabs and they
didn't observe rhythmic behavior in
rodents rats and mice until about 1924
or something like that so basically the
history of clocks is the history of
plant clocks and animals are recent
interlopers in plants basically whatever
you're doing there's a good chance that
there will be an influence of time of
day on that phenomenon which is really
an inconvenient truth but it's my
assertion to you and so we know that a
growth responses elongation growth
happens it's gated two particular times
a day there are many examples of
metabolic gating of course we know the
clock influences for the periodic
flowering
and and and recent events and I'll show
a couple of examples that have provided
evidence that the ability to mount to
receive and mount a response to biotic
or abiotic stresses can be a function of
the time of day at which that stress is
encountered so they're really quite
pervasive do rhythms matter I want to
give you two examples where they do
matter the first I think is in many ways
the coolest this is words from Alexander
Graff who was a student with Allison
Smith and it has to do with starch
metabolism basically a rabbit ops Asst
stores it's photosynthesis excess
photosynthate in the day as starch and
then at night degrades that to provide
carbon for growth or respiration and and
of course it would be bad if you burned
it all up and ran out what happens is
that at dusk the plant makes a
calculation how much starch should I
accumulate today Consultants a clock and
anticipates when Don is going to be and
adjusts its starch degradation rates to
be linear such that starch reserves are
just about but not quite exhausted at
dawn if you full it by a delaying dawn
the plant does this linear burn runs out
of starch induces a carbon starvation
response and and growth falls off
dramatically so so here's one great
example that may be why it's important
to have a clock to do this calculation
and and of course the title of one of
the reviews was plants do arithmetic
division I just love that the other one
here's another one for those of you who
like caterpillars so cabbage loopers
like to devour rabid Oxus and so a good
speed at all in Jennifer Anne's lab did
some totally cool experiment they
entrained the loopers in the plants in
phase with one another so they both
think days when day is and there's an
activity rhythm and a feeding rhythm the
the troika blue C&E are active during
the daytime and and if they're in phase
with the plants everybody thinks it's
daytime and and there's some or bibury
and some growth of the loopers but the
plants survive if
however you would train the plants and
the loopers out of phase with one
another such that the looper is active
when it thinks it's day but the presence
at night the plants are devastated and
and and the loopers proliferate and get
big and fat and and of course now what
we know is they're cycling jazz monic
acid levels and and the planet of course
there's a trade-off between defense and
growth and the plant is just making j:a
when it anticipates the activity rhythm
of the looper and it seems if you
disrupt that relationship it's bad news
for the plants so here are two examples
but there are many many other examples I
mean we don't know exactly there's no
one thing you can look at and say this
is why clocks enhancefitness
so far it's probably an incremental
improvement on lots of different
processes and it you know which you
think is most important what do we call
that an ascertain meant by assits
whatever you think is important and you
can look at it and you'll find it may be
so to define some terms
so circadian the term means that's from
the latin approximately a circuit
approximately da so these are rhythms
that have a period length of
approximately but not exactly 24 hours
and they're endogenous they persist in
the absence of environmental time cues
but of course we live in a world that's
replete with environmental time cues and
so clocks are entrain about to
environmental time cues keep chiefly
light-dark cycles but also temperature
cycles in the case of you folks most of
whom I think are humans if you fly to
Japan you're going to be jet-lagged the
light-dark cycles take a walk at noon
that'll help you in train but also
social cues taking your meals on time
having a beer at the end of the day all
these sorts of social tools will help to
entrain your clock so just see a couple
of terms that I'll mention a bit I won't
mention amplitude much that it's your
sine wave physics from from high school
half the peak to trough distance is one
amplitude in a training conditions when
we're providing a light dark cycle the
period will be entrained to 24 hours if
you're released into continuous
conditions the gray is when the lights
would have gone off had they gone off
you'll see revealed the freerunning
period in this example
a little longer than 24 about 25 hours
so traditionally we thought about the
clock in sort of a linear cascade
there's a clock it's in trained through
input pathways like temperature
imbibition in this case I mean that
hydration of the seed but that's the
social cues of taking a beer on time
will help you in trace and then their
output rhythms gene expression I'll talk
about I'll talk a lot about leaf
movements the mental aperture other
things but this linear pathway is not
sufficient to think about this because
we know there's dating that is the plant
through clock regulated expression for
example of phytochromes modulates its
own sensitivity to light so and we can
think about that with a plant but also
with us a pulse of light applied to you
at noon doesn't affect your clock of
course cursors light at noon but that
same pulse of light applied to you in
the pre-dawn hours you think oh my
goodness I've overslept the click the
light Sun lights a run already and you
advance your clock to match what you've
now perceived as a new dawn that same
pulse of light applied to you after dusk
you think oh I thought the Sun went down
but it just went down again and you
delay your clock so so it's very
contextual it's time of day dependent
that's this gating phenomenon in
addition many of the output pathways
have intermediates and it's now becoming
clear in a number of ways that various
intermediates in these output path
weights metabolites like sugars
nutrients like organic nitrogen iron
copper are actually feeding back again
to modulate clock function and so if
you're setting up all these to be
appropriate at time of day and they're
interacting with the rest of the
organism of course you're monitoring key
metabolites to try and fine-tune the
clock so so it's not a linear pathway at
all it's a network pathway and you have
to think of the the clock I think as an
integrator of cellular metabolism and
organismal physiology at least that's
the way I'm trying to think about it
work from a lot of labs among them that
of Steve Kay in a rabbit offices have
done a long way towards defining the
architecture and the components and the
interrelationships of these components
in
and the plant clock and so uh like all
these complicated machines it gets
complex and then people simplify that it
gets complex again we're in a period of
slight simplification but basically
there are a whole bunch of transcription
factors most of which are repressors at
dawn cca1 and LH y2 single mid doing
transcription factors are abundant and
they repress a whole bunch of other
things so there's this morning component
they're also evening components and
these are arrayed according to times of
day so there's an evening complex and
talk 1 and and these guys are also
repressors what happens is after a
period of time certain transcriptional
activators turn on this bridging group
and they turn off this and and so on and
you with all this interrelated on/off
you can build up a stable 24-hour
oscillation with these feedback loops
and and depending on your love of
complexity you can add way more arrows
and more components to this and it does
look a little bit like a hairball so the
real question now to me well one of the
real questions is is rapid ops is a good
model can we take this and move it in to
apply it to other plants and so that was
a challenge in particularly I didn't
really want to take on that challenge
but of course when the plant genome
project got going at the NSF plant
genome means any plant genome except for
that of a rabbit abscess and so I needed
to if I wanted to get money I needed to
find a crop and my friend and
collaborator Cynthia Lennox said got the
system for you I found a great
population of hominid ate bread lines
and Brassica Rapa and so said ok let's
put in a grant to work on that we did
and got funded and so now many years
later we're still working on it
so transition to a crop Brassica Rapa
it's just it's it's a rabid office on
steroids rabid offices flower abrasca
flower a rabbit out succeed braska seed
rabbit up cecilia braska seedling so its
bigger but it's very similar and then
there are a couple of other twists will
come up it's a cult
big drop napa cabbage turnip chinese
cabbage it's highly play morphic show
you slide on that later but also an
invasive weed but of course it related
to a rabbit opposites but also to maybe
a mega crop like being Canadian of
course canola so we thought this was a
good place to start and and oh yeah I
didn't really realize at the time but
Brassica Rapa doesn't transform terribly
well and that's really a limitation but
we wanted a nice non-invasive
non-transgenic assay and for that we
went back to the assay that drove
circadian rhythm research for many
millennia that is leaf movement and so
uh this abrasca seedling and this is
what these guys do just the leaves go up
and down once a day for the cotyledons
the true leaves do as well and I'll come
back to this later but we wanted to
greatly enhance our true put when we
first did our first recombinant inbred
line population was 150 lines we did it
three temperatures and that's a tree
postdoc years and uh what we wanted to
do was scale up and steal from that
buckler's playbook and start looking at
nested Association napping populations
and look at more and so we went through
a thousand and fifty genotypes and I
didn't have like thirty postdoc years
there was no way that was going to
happen so we had to streamline the
analytic pipeline and the problem is
there's just too much operator input and
so I went to a friend of mine this guy
here honey Farid who is chair of our
computer science department and I said
honey I know in your deep dark past you
did automated motion detection you have
any code that can help us with this and
he said he thought he could and so he
wrote this great code uh that basically
takes successive frames a pixel and
draws a motion vector from where that
pixel is in frame one for a man to where
it is in print n plus one and that's
what these blue lines are these motion
vectors going from frame to frame and
then you simply sum all the vectors at
each interval and then you can plot out
a motion and it's totally uh it's a user
free I just click one button and you get
the whole thing back from all your
plants so uh if we go
honey I want you back uh so we plot that
out you get nice automated digital
readout that's quantitative and we can
then do a Fourier transform and extract
the rhythmic parameters on that and so
up here are traces from the two parents
of this recombinant inbred line
population um this one is much taller
and as you can see it's growing very
quickly but basically they look pretty
similar they go up and down once a day
and and this is what they actually look
like the oilseed is is yellow narrows
center seed code so you can pack more
oil in there the rapid cycler imv 211
has dark seeds and you can see this is
bigger but this guy's already flowering
it's a rapid sector so there were little
different recombinant inbred line
population generated from these and so
first we want to know is there variation
among accession to Brassica Rapa in
terms of circadian parameters so we just
went to a Dutch sock Center and got
fifty cultivated accessions measured
circadian period length of three
different temperatures and we saw quite
a range of skating period lengths we
then applied that divided and fifty were
dominated grid lines and in every case
we see transgressive variation and a lot
of variation every bit as much variation
among these lines derived from the two
parents that are indicated by the circle
and the square as we saw in this global
collection so we can map QTL and so
while we were mapping QTL cynthia was
not first Akkadian period Cynthia was
mapping QTL for all kinds of
morphometric parameters and
physiological parameters and the idea
was then we bring the two together and
it correlates them and ask is clock
function contributing to some of these
other functions when we did this we
observed the QTL at this position on
chromosome 9 and so at this point the
Brassica genome had just been released
we had a sense of what candidate genes
were there and now I want to introduce
one of the complications
Brassica Rapa is just like a rabid
abscess
on steroids perhaps but since since the
separation of Arabidopsis from for
abrasca from Arabidopsis it's undergone
a whole genome replication and so we
mapped out where all the various
candidate genes were based on symphony
with the rabbit axis and we had a
candidate underlying this one vetted
where there was only one copy had been
retained after polyploid ization you get
a lot of fractionation a lot of gene
loss we thought if we pick one whether
it's just a single copy life would
potentially be simpler and the gene
underlying that particular queue tail
was a gene called gigantea which is
known in a rabid opposites to be
important for flowering time loss of
function mutation is very late flowering
and also for CKD n' function so we
thought that's a good candidate so the
first thing we did was try and confirm
genetically that there really was a gene
in that region and we were lucky in
doing this nobody had McNeil's or
something like this but we got the
population of rills very early they were
only been solved about three times and
so there was still a lot of residual
hetero zygosity so we could take one of
the reals that was heterozygous over the
QTL and simply sell fit and generate a
two parents in an otherwise somewhat I
guess background with the parental DNA
either from our 500 or imv to 11 in
doing that we we had a recombination
event that that greatly reduced the
interval we could simply compare these
two lines and indeed there was a
statistically significant difference in
period that was consistent imb to 11 as
a longer period than our 500 so okay
there's something there
if gigantea were to be the genus
responsible presumably there'd be some
sort of polymorphism between the two
alleles so we resequenced the two
alleles we found a ton of snips three of
which were actually predicted to be
missense mutations changing the amino
acid sequence a Assyrian to alanine and
so on and so forth so then we went right
to the transgenic endgame I told you we
can't transform braska terribly well so
we just went into a rabid opposites put
the breast allele central rabid odds
and and we got very lucky and got a home
run with the first experiment because
when we introduced the IMD allele into a
rabid abscess nothing happened at
circadian period late but when we
introduced the r500 aliyah and that's
the one with shorter period Braska we
had a significant shortening of
circadian period length there were three
mutations so we started making chimeric
genes and ultimately the final thing
which simply made point mutation to
recapitulate this mutation and so the
imb to 11 allele that doesn't shortens
Akkadian period length if we simply make
that one nucleotide change to change
that amino acid to the r500 version it
now shortens period and the current furs
are 500 shortens period but if we change
that back to the IMD residue at that
position feels the shortened period so
that's the gene and that's the
nucleotide and that's the amino acid
responsible for this by chemically
mechanistically we don't understand but
but that is the mutation it's not like
the two alleles one is active the other
is inactive because both alleles fully
rescue the late flowering phenotype of a
loss-of-function giganteus so they're
active equally active for flowering
timing and and gigantea turned out to be
we didn't know when we started this but
it's pretty interesting because it does
a lot of things we know about there was
a hyper continent i p-- difference and
and and everything in that totally puts
Akkadian period applies to the hypo
caudal phenotype also it turns out loss
of gigantea function in a rabid abscess
confers tolerance to cold enhances
tolerance to cold and that's seen here
it's able to tolerate lower temperatures
than wild-type and the imb 211 allele
eliminates that whereas the r500 allele
does not and the chimera genes behave
consistently and there's a similar
phenotype that I took out apparently
with salt tolerance and and that behaves
the same so we wanted to ask okay that's
all in a rabbit abscess
this mutation matter and do the same
things in Brassica Rapa and for that
I've always regard relied on the
kindness of friends and large district
art at the John Innes Institute had
developed a spectacular tilling
population in an oilseed roa team that's
closely related are 500 and so we sent
him 2,500 bucks and he sent us 22
alleles of gigantea including four of
which were presumptive loss-of-function
and and so here are two of them and it's
late flowering a loss of gigantea late
flowering enhances freezing tolerance
and enhances salt tolerance in Brassica
Rapa so it's behaving quite similar in
to the rabbit opposite story
it also doesn't do much the circadian
rhythmicity at 18 degrees but at 22
degrees really flattens out the rhythm
is a big loss of amplitude so it's clock
active as well there so we got a QTL
braska as I mentioned is a highly plant
play morphic resonance and there's leafy
vegetables of course we're more familiar
in in North America with the ola ratio
equivalents where it's cabbage and
brussel sprouts and cauliflower and
broccoli and so on and so forth and and
a lot of this may be because of this
triplet ization providing the material
for diversification and and of course we
know the gene duplication underlies the
radiation of the angiosperms below all
the importance of division see right
before the ancestral gene plant that was
all genome duplication before the
ancestral angiosperm is all genome
duplication if you're a rabbit UPS
eccentric you're familiar with the gamma
beta and alpha duplications on the road
to a rabbit OPS's but this little
triangle up here in Brassica Rapa is
this recent whole genome triplication
that's gone on there and and so
typically these events are followed by a
great deal of fractionation a lot of
gene laws and so when we wanted to
evaluate candidates for our clock qtls
we wanted to map all the various
Ravin abscess clock genes on the basis
of synthetic position and and when we
did that we realized we could ask a
question our clock genes fractionated
loss at the same rate as everything else
or are they somehow different and and
Jim birch ler and my frailing have
elaborated this dosage hypothesis it
says that that genes that are highly
networked or genes that are dosage
dependent cannot be lost
following a whole genome duplication
because you throw off that dosage
balance and of course all the genes in
the clock are are semi dominant and
dosage sensitive and so we thought well
maybe they're preferentially retained
and when we started looking we started
thinking this might be the case here's
one gene family of five suitor response
regulators here are 9 7 5 3 and P R 1
which is also more commonly known as
talk 1 and you'll notice for PR 5
there's three copies for pair 9 there's
two copies two copies for pair seven
looks like they're preferentially
retained perhaps and so we compared the
clock genes to the 10 synthetic genes
around each of the clock genes and the
clock genes about 60% of them are
routine in rapa whereas only about 40%
of the synthetic genes work so yeah they
are preferentially retained and it could
be that this this whole genome
duplication business implants underlies
the proliferation of clock genes and and
it just empirically when you look at the
hairballs to describe the oscillator in
animals versus plants they look a little
more complicated in plants and and and
so if you look from a single-celled alga
through Moss to a rabid abscess Nebraska
you can just see a proliferation of
potential clock genes and so we're very
curious whether or not this has a
whether there's now neo
functionalisation and a sub
functionalisation in rapid relative to
what we know in a rabid offices I'm not
going to talk about that today but those
are ongoing projects in the lab so we
wanted to describe the circadian
transcriptome in in rapa and so we just
set up video a classic experiment you in
training plants so a light dark cycle
release them
into continuous light in temperature and
we've harvested tissue every two hours
for 48 hours using this oil seed our 500
and starting to look at this and and so
here's a set of clock genes they're
present three of them are present in two
copies in rapa third ones present and
three copies so just in this survey and
this is representative what we see and
other people have seen typically when
you start looking at one of these
polyploids you can fractionate the
genomes and and there will be a dominant
genome and a sub dominant genome or
genomes well one of the genomes is
expressed at higher level than the other
and we see that here one copy of LH why
that mid domain transcription factors
expressed at higher level than the other
same with talked one same with there are
seven the same seer with p RR v where b
or v is what we're calling the c copy
here is expressed at higher level but
now we start seeing evidence perhaps of
perhaps and sub functionalisation going
on because you'll notice one of these
genes here are 5b is peeking earlier
than the other to see and a and and so
we don't know if these are now starting
to subdivide functions up or acquire new
functions but certainly in terms of the
pattern of transcript abundance we're
starting to see changes and we see this
in some but not in all of the genes so
if you start trying to sort these out
and the various clustering algorithms
we're using on network analysis to look
at this one of the predominant things
when you sort the transcriptome is time
of date and we can sort this out in two
clusters on the basis of time of day of
the peak transcript abundance ZT that's
a site Gaber time it's from the german
timegiver
dawn the last light dark electrons
transition is ET zero and then you scale
from them and if you're doing a light
dark cycle you go ZT
zero up to 24 which becomes zero again
and so we can bend them out according to
phase and see clusters of genes and all
the different times this is just the
first few phases we can start also doing
a network analysis for example in the
family of the free purify genes and a5b
that speaking early is now in a network
that's distinct from the two copies of
5c and 5a that are peeking a little
later and these have targets in grey
that are in common as well as own Co
Express not targets but Co expressed
genes and so we're starting to see some
subdivision of the networks among the
different copies and we think that may
be offering the opportunity for greater
complexity in in fractioning a genome
expression but we don't know yet it's
very early days we wanted to start
looking at response to biotic stresses
and and I mentioned up gating the idea
that the ability to mount a response
will be a function at the time of day at
which that the stress is encountered and
and so that sort of Illustrated here if
we provide a stress say at this point we
might get one response we apprised on we
might get one response if we provided a
dusk we might get a different response
on a basic transcript cycle um generally
what people encounter when they do this
is they see if there's a basal rhythm in
the transcript it tends it to be that
the peak in response to a perturbation
tends to be at the time of peak
expression this was first observed by
Andrew Miller working with Steve K she
quite a while ago now just looking at
the light induce ability of cab genes
and and they peak in about the middle of
the morning and that turns out to be if
you put them in the dark and given
pulses of light you trace their basal
waveform on their induce ability or
their induce ability simply mimics that
when they're maximally expressed that's
when you get maximum induction and so
we're anticipating seeing something like
this
and so we wanted to and and this has
been seen by Mike Thomas shows lab for
example in cold induction of the CBS
where if you provide a cold pulse for
hours after done you get strong
induction if you ride the same cold post
16 hours after done you get very minimal
induction and so there's the circadian
gating of the induction of the cold
regular so we wanted to look at drought
why well corn yields if you look you
know whenever there's a dip often that's
associated with draw a dry year and so
we thought we could look at this also uh
Olivia Wilkins had suggested that there
was a circadian gating of drought
responses in both rabbit abscess and
poplar so we thought this would be a
good place to look in Brassica Rapa and
and we know that there's likely to be a
clock intersection from some Arab adopts
this work we know that if you perturb
the expression of talk one either over
express it or do a knockdown or a loss
of function mutation on you see effects
on stomatal aperture in response to ABA
the closing is is attenuated by talk one
over expression we know that a triple
loss of function mutation of three of
the PRRS here are nine seven and five
enhances drug tolerance in a rabid
once's and so we thought that you know
there's good evidence suggesting this in
the o'clock intersection with the
drought response and so we went after
this our collaborators particularly of
brent yours and lena lasagna at the
university of wyoming spent a lot of
time trying to get conditions where they
could withhold water and and get a
gradual loss of soil water moisture and
look in the earliest stages of the
drought response and that that's what
we're trying to do here here's a soil
moisture in well watered verses our
dreaded plants over we would held water
a day before this so we're looking in
the second and third days of drought
here and and we're seeing only small
changes in the mental conductance in the
well-watered versus the drier climate so
it
very early response these are a long way
from from wilting and so we're going to
look these guys that Wyoming guys are
going to look at a lot of physiological
parameters and we're going to look at
the transcriptomic response and the 50
of it so they measured a photosynthetic
rate semental conductance photosystem 2
efficiency non-structural carbohydrates
and and there are not much for
photosynthetic rate but we see a tomato
conductance changes with it depleted and
the dreaded plants late in the day sort
of what you might expect we see perhaps
compensations in photosystem 2
efficiency which seems to be slightly
greater in the dreaded plants that Wow
maybe why a photosynthetic carbon
assimilation doesn't fall off and we see
some changes that they're significant
but I'm not sure I understand them at
all in non structural carbohydrates but
there are subtle physiological changes
in the plant when we look at the
transcriptome one of the things we see
that's predicted from what Olivia
Wilkins had done is that if you do a
cladogram the drought and well-watered
plants cluster together according to
time of day so there's a massive Reese
culling of the transcriptome in response
to the clock there's big time of day
changes about a third of the
transcriptome cycles depending on where
and how you look and so what we what we
actually see then is is the time of day
signal is predominant over any response
to this slight drought condition and so
what we're looking at for subtle changes
we're doing a way to gene correlation
analysis team correlation expression and
out network analysis yeah and so we're
going to split this up we're going to
make grouted Network drought 'add and a
well water Network we're going to
establish consensus by comparing the two
and then we're going to look for a
modules groups of core express genes
that respond and are correlated with the
physiological data
and unique to the dreaded Network that's
what we're trying to do and it's very
early days in this analysis but we can
we can set up and the different modules
are colored color-coordinated and we can
do that with well watered and drought it
and we can split them up into modules
the top eight modules from each network
contain about 80 85 percent of the 80 to
85 percent of the expressed genes in
these top modules are cycling that's the
way to phrase it and so if we can take a
well-watered network and and that that
shows here at the eigen gene expression
it's peeking in the middle of the day
and then if we re-examine those genes
actually they now subdivided into three
sub networks one that looks much like
the parental network unperturbed but to
this network in this network you can see
a broadening of the peak in the daytime
and here's sort of a broadening and a
phase advance trout of the trough and so
these are subtle responses and how and
of course we don't at this point know
that they're functionally important but
we can start seeing perturbations of in
response to drought so if we look at
these physiological traits we can
correlate them with the expression
profiles and we can observe for example
here's a group that's positively
correlated with the physiology with a
first carbon assimilation here's an
example of a group a module that's
negatively correlated with Fe over FM in
doing in creating this curve we we
flipped to an absolute take an absolute
value and that's why it looks like a
positive correlation it is a negative
correlation and then there's of course
other modules that simply are not
correlated with semental conductance in
this regard what we're starting to see
are things where you know they're
peaking in the throat and not or the
amplitude of the peak is up in drought
versus well water conditions and you
know inspection by eye when you look at
this okay here's the pattern that I told
you in the
a water network in the well water this
transcript is peaking and the amplitude
is increased under dreaded conditions
but of course inspection by I is pretty
unsatisfying so we've tried a number of
things we've taken a pro trying to
identify rhythmic genes is one of the
challenges in in transcriptomic level
analysis and some people John Hogan and
his colleagues at Penn have developed
something called JDK cycle that is a way
of evaluating the significance of
rhythmicity and phase and so we're
comparing individual transcripts in the
drought in in well water and we're
looking for transcripts that either are
not rhythmic and routed and acquire
ethnicity in well water are not rhythmic
in well water and acquire ethnicity and
routed or the converse or ones where
there's an amplitude change either up or
down and and this program is working
fairly well for pulling those out so
we're getting genes in that regard and
we can build networks among these genes
here's for example a network of drug
responsive genes that are positively
correlated with the metal conductors and
and it's actually three overlapping
networks and there are conversely drug
responsive genes that are negatively
correlated instrumental conductance so
we're trying to parse out the
transcriptome in this sense but our
analysis is far from complete and then
of course the hard thing is going to be
to relate specific changes with
differential drug response now when does
this end okay okay so we wanted to scale
up and I gave you my my Hani spiel about
how we could scale up and so we wanted
to look at a lot of different plants
across the eudicots
and so when we did that we could observe
in a rabid abscess and other braska but
we went into things like NIMH ulis and
as far as soybean and and it turns out
that this new program that Hani wrote
for us that we call trip tracking
rhythms and
seems to be generally applicable across
the US and that allowed us to to
investigate one of the things that I've
been really interested in and started
out talking with is there some sort of
can we evaluate a fitness effect of
clock performance and so we started out
looking in soybeans and and you know
soybeans it's a different type of rhythm
but beliefs go up and down quite nicely
and and of course you can get the motion
vectors on it and so we can do this so
what we did was we we went to Monsanto
and got 50 elite cultivars and and these
cultivars have been extensively bred for
basically flowering time and yield
performance in latitudinal zones they
call them maturity zones but basically
they're they're grown in these
latitudinal zones and when we looked at
circadian period in these 50 elite
cultivars that nobody's messed with her
clock nobody measured the clock but we
observed a significant positive
correlation of period with latitude as
you move farther north the period
lengthens so were the Monsanto breeders
inadvertently selecting for circadian
period Lynx perhaps certainly all they
were looking for was performance of in
these latitudinal zones so we see this
correlation ah it was a great conceit to
get it from Monsanto because of course
no one's going to doubt that they're
well bred the problem is it's the end of
the road
they might know what the genes are but
we're not going to know what the genes
are the agreement didn't include access
to that so but we've repeated this now
in in a wild population of monkeys our
emulous and a John Willis and Josh Suzy
are collected accessions of NIMH ulis
that grows all the way from the Mexican
border up well into Canada the Queen
Charlotte Islands so a huge latitudinal
range and it is a - we call it natural
history lifestyle habits annual and
perennial among the annuals there's an
even stronger positive correlation of
latitude and Sukie
in period so we're we're hoping to go is
to take these genotypes and start doing
the common garden experiments and ask
does circadian performance contribute to
Fitness in the different latitudes so
that's where we want to go with this we
haven't done that yet and we've expanded
dramatically a high fruit sort of
allowed us to now look at large numbers
of populations of a rabid axis and this
is our set all we're using now it's
where are we
that's a canon powershot it only till
there year old you go to Home Depot
they're cheap you can get them you hack
in and overwrite the software and
tournaments time-lapse machines and and
what Hani's program allows us to do is
capture 120 seedlings and then
immediately converted into individual
seedling image temporal image stacks and
then do the entire analysis and release
period and faith data for that seedling
and that's seedling in that seedling
with one click of the button so the
analytic pipeline is really smooth and
so we can we can fit 14 cameras into our
our growth room and and so here's an
example of looking at seven populations
of all against a common female parent
called zero
this figure is four-and-a-half million
images and it was about 30 times faster
than preceding one so it Hannie is a
genius as far as I'm concerned and and
so you get what has been shown if you
analyze the individual populations you
get some QTL for skating period a fairly
low LOD scores if you do the combined
analysis the LOD scores go way up in
significance gives you increased
statistical power and so now we're very
interested in trying to identify some of
these this one we think might be our old
friends I gets here this one well the
candidate there is pr7 this one in the
middle of four is as far as we know
novel and so we're pretty excited if we
could actually get a new clock team from
this quantitative approach that'd be
terrific to do this with a thousand and
fifty genotypes with all the replication
you know we had to do randomized block
design
and and the postdocs kadian paying came
to me and said you know we can't stand
the idea of throwing away the seedlings
after we've measured leaflessness
what else can we look at we thought
about this and we thought well let's go
back to their example of starch so we
then took all these plants rid them a
little longer in a light dark cycle and
then harvested them and sent them off
the market in Germany for starch
analysis and metabolite analysis so now
on the same population we can measure
circadian QTL and QTL for residual
starch prior to dawn and when we do that
they really drag their feet doing it
because they didn't think anything
exciting was going to come out and they
discovered more variation in residual
starts and it was like an order of
magnitude more than they'd ever seen and
they were pretty excited so now we have
QTL for a circadian period and starch
and sometimes it's one or the other and
sometimes it's both so we're really
hoping Marc and Alison Smith and I have
just submitted a proposal to pursue this
identify some of the genes and really
look at this interplay of the clock with
starch metabolism and and it was amazing
in six of the populations you'd predict
if you had a long circadian period you'd
anticipate dawn farther out so you'd be
burning your starch at a slower rate and
you'd have more residual starch and in
every population when you there's a
positive correlation between period and
residual starch and in three of the
populations it's fairly significant so
it looks like that's borne out across
season so we're pretty excited at
pursuing this so that's that's where
we're going to be going I never would
have thought I would be interested in
starch but Marc and Alison of Maeda
have converted me back in Brassica Rik a
matheno and Scot would have been
preparing a series of populations in
this messes association mapping strategy
so we're hoping to repeat this type of
work in Brassica Rapa ah of course I
didn't do any of this myself it's a
product of mostly some great postdocs
Katie Victor ping a former postdoc Chi
Guang I mentioned Hani a couple of
visiting scientists darling and Jenna
from China and Korea
and a horde of really good
undergraduates current honours thesis
student and a whole bunch of
collaborator so plant genome work has
been with Rick and Scott and Cynthia and
Brin and Lena and Todd and Malia and
then some collaborators some
collaborators in South Korea and let's
see Ganesh and Cindy gave us the soybean
cultivars John and Josh all the numerous
cultivars and and mark this is an
optimistic collaboration we're just
getting started and hopefully it'll lead
to exciting things and of course I want
to thank the National Science Foundation
and the Rural Development the agency I
in South Korea for supporting this work
and thank you for your attention oh we
glad to try to answer any questions
[Applause]
620 rhythms great yeah that's a little
controversial a Hyun mo did an
experiment that suggested mutations in
cca1 and taequan didn't affect the route
clock people have revisited that and
there is a route clock and it looks like
there is a lot of a guy named endo I
forget his first name Japanese fellow
starting it was a postdoc with CK's got
his own lab in Japan has been looking
systematically and there are different
of the clocks in different tissues are
functioning slightly differently so
there's an epidermal clock and a means
of o'clock and a vascular clock and a
root clock and then Paloma mas dinner in
in Barcelona did a really interesting
experiment where she excised the shoot
apical meristem and discovered that the
root clock stopped running and so it
looks like there may be some
hierarchical relationships among these
so that's a very active area but yeah
there is a root clock we knew that I bet
I didn't show you these data but I've
been collaborating with my wife Mary Lou
Guerin Oh who's Elena's buddy and she
studies iron homeostasis and it turns
out I would always be a pain in the butt
at every one of our student seminars and
say what time of day to do the
experiment
they would say shut up Rob and so I
would finally my Korean postdoc got
together with her Korean postdoc and
finally did the experiment and uh the
reductase that reduces the iron and the
transport of the transports the iron in
both show up sir
strongly iron inducible so you only see
this you're doing under iron starvation
conditions but their circadian gated so
they peak dramatically at one particular
time of day so yes the clock is
regulating iron homeostasis in the root
so there clearly has to be a root clock
and and so we're collaborating on trying
to figure out how that works but we're
still pretty much in the dark just just
an issue at the same experiment at in
hopes given trying to unless you may
stretch in this post-apocalyptic ation
and we found like the date about all of
the ways and then you fix the time over
in a collection and all of its
variations on so it's a step turns out
this experiment has been done over and
over many many many of my collaborators
and colleagues in the circadian field
started out doing gene expression and
one postdoc couldn't reproduce the
graduate students and one was a lark and
one with an owl and they fought like
cats and dogs and then suddenly they
realize they're both right and so that
drag has dragged a lot of people into
the clock fields and kicking and
screaming typically yeah I think it's a
pretty good ad question uh whether it's
those I wish all guys don't you shoot
exactly or for detection about the exact
thing that they really should keep and
where it is and it recommends us to
Center the Yuma image yeah if if you
start doing you know laser dissection or
protoplast thing and sorting you can
start seeing in these
epidermis needs a fill vascular tissue
in the leaf for example you can see
slightly different profiles of different
profiles of gene expression and and
different mutations affect different
clocks a different
specific clocks norm so we haven't done
any of that ourselves but that's
definitely a growth industry in the area
and we real everything I've shown you
and everything I've done is a leaf
lamina uh so predominantly means a fill
but with with epidermis in there and we
showed Todd Michael when he was a grad
student in my lab did some experiments
where he challenged a provided
light-dark cycles or temperature cycles
and he would put them in opposition to
one another sort of this gladiator
experiment asked which is more important
and it turns out the answer depends on
which target you're looking at so
Musical Express gene like cab responded
primarily to light rather than
temperature but an epidermal catalase
responded primarily to temperature
rather than light and so there's going
to be a great deal of complexity there
that is only beginning to be explored
yeah yeah so there are so many genes
involved in keeping this oscillating
Network going but would you look at qgl
you get you know a few big Peaks it
looks like and some of them are genes
that you know are in offices like two
guys yet is there anything about those
QTL genes and their position in the core
expression network are they more
connected they occupy like traditional
positions between modules that's
informative or we haven't seen that yet
but but but basically you know big
intervals and very few of the actual
genes have been identified Seth Davis
has identified elf free in one
population and we've identified gigantea
in a different species in a population
we have a good candidate for one in a
rabid office now but so we don't know
enough to know about that but also you
know the LOD scores are misleading
because each one of those you know I
wish we had you know a really large
effect gene but each each one of these
QTL I think the largest one we've seen
is is accounting for 10 or 15 percent of
the variation in the trait so there
aren't these are definitely not behaving
like Mendelian low side
you know they well
you know in it's not they're not large
effect so it makes it more challenging
but perhaps more interesting and you've
exactly articulated part of our
interests and in pursuing this will that
turn out to be true love and if it were
so you said you are showing that um
Klein of the month sentence would be
superhuman show Klein in clocks such as
the Icelandic population by and large
have a different kind of clock or I have
a difference and I know you say we can
train but I'm asking whether there is a
genetic component to the clock uh I
don't know of any study that's been
looking geographically in that regard
but but we do know that there's a
genetic basis in the clock for a number
of human pathologies so advanced
familial sleep syndrome and delayed
familiar suite syndrome underlying that
are our mutations in canonical clock
genes like pers females and so on so
whether or not there will be a clock
function thing I I don't know if we've
been in those latitudes long enough uh
but it's a really interesting question
to explore and people are starting to do
this more and more they've had to really
it used to be when I started in the
field they thought that we all ran
really quite long and and that was you
know the way they did the studies has it
turns out it was an artifact because
they take somebody typically a PhD
student who wanted to write their thesis
or a professor who wanted to write their
monographs
and so they wanted to be left alone so
they volunteered for one of these cave
or bunker studies and they'd go you know
underground for some period of time and
write their thesis and then when they'd
open the door to let them out they'd say
hey no come on I'm counting the days
I've got another week to go here and I
haven't finished my last chapter but
that's because the clock was running a
little long but they gave him control of
the light switch and it turns out that
lights in the evening delay your clock
so just with the presence of light in
the evening they were
actually artificially lengthening the
period of their clock which is of course
why you don't do your email right before
bed
and and so now now to do these studies
it's not so fun because they strap you
down in a dim room and intubate you and
you know put an IV in and give you 200
calories every you know etc etc and our
period is much more as a species is much
closer to 24 hours than we thought and I
I don't know what the range is I think
though I don't think they've done hurt a
lot of people yet but it would be really
interesting to look at maybe that's why
the Scandinavians are depressive or
something I don't know maybe it's
because there's no Sun sports manic
manic depressive is right now I'm kind
of moving into the manic phase I love
this time of year and maybe that's just
because it's been so dark for so long I
think the hannover weather is much like
the epic or whether she's in that regard
alright well people thanking their all
for the seminar the announcements for
the students are open utilized so please
come up to the seminar
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu